all right it's it seems like we're back
this supposedly urgent press briefing
with Kaylee mackaninee was scheduled for
1:00 p.m. Eastern time which was 45
minutes ago and then it was rescheduled
to 2 p.m. Eastern time which is 15
minutes from now so I'm back hopefully
there won't be another delay honestly I
don't know how urgent this really is I
mean I think the urgency is that Donald
Trump is hugely hugely failing he's
fired his campaign manager but tried to
make it seem like everything's fine he's
got 36 percent approval in a recent
Quinnipiac poll so I don't know I don't
know exactly what the urgency is or
what's gonna be going on but there seems
to be renewed interest in what is coming
out of this administration over the last
few days I don't know what is causing it
but the interest in the streams of these
Trump administration events has been off
the charts Lisa recently on Tuesday I
believe my stream across all platforms
had 41,000 live viewers I haven't even
done anything yet and across platforms
we're already at 4,000 right now and I
mean nothing's even happened yet so
something seems to be going on where
people want answers people want to hear
like is does this administration have
any plan and I have a big story coming
up tomorrow on the show which I kind of
go into on today's podcast a little bit
which is and in fact I tweeted about it
let me see if I can find it here it was
this morning that I tweeted about it
here it is
people need to realize Trump is out of
time to win reelection by dealing with
coronavirus it takes 8 to 10 weeks to
flatten the curve of cases another three
weeks for deaths his only options are
dirty tricks and it's about to get
insane so let's just look at New York as
an example because New York was one of
the big early hotspots I don't remember
exactly when New York locked down but I
think it was around this area and what
you can see is when the lockdown started
in mid to late march cases continued
going up for two weeks they plateaued
for about ten days
then came down and the cases only got to
a reasonable level about two and a half
months after the lockdown started right
so we're now on June July 16th if these
states like just to take an example and
I'll pick Florida because we're gonna
get while Florida 14,000 more cases
today unbelievable if you look at
Florida's curve they're not even at
their peak but imagine that they lock
down today and we immediately got over
the peak it takes two weeks to get to
the peak when you lock down we're
already looking at October before the
cases get under control in Florida the
deaths lag the cases usually by 14 to 20
days depends on you know number of
different factors so if Florida was
willing to fully lock down today we
would be getting it under control in
Florida around election day but Florida
doesn't seem willing to actually lock
down so you know it's it what the point
is the idea of Trump seeing the virus
under control by election day as his
path to victory it's mathematically an
impossibility it's just not going to
happen and so dirty tricks are what
we're going to expect now just briefly a
couple of different things one remember
this guy
Kevin's tit this is the governor of
Oklahoma and he posted in mid-march when
some reasonable states were were closing
down he posted bragging about how he was
out at a restaurant eating with my kids
and all my fellow Oklahomans at the
collective okay see it's PAC tonight
very very big party happening there
sadly governor Kevin's tit has
contracted the corona virus as Mike
Pence calls it Oklahoma governor Kevin's
tit announces he has tested positive for
corona virus Oklahoma Governor Kevin's
tit who has aggressively pushed to
reopen his state and floated health
experts recommendations floated experts
health recommendations rather announced
Wednesday that he is the first governor
to test positive for corona virus he's
leading he has taken the initiative of
becoming the first governor to get
corona virus and he said he feels fine
other than being a little bit a
he he did a press conference while
positive for coronavirus okay he'll be
quarantine and working from home and he
was pretty shocked to be the first
governor to get the virus I want to use
my story to remind Oklahomans that if
you aren't feeling well we want you to
get tested oh that's MDI that that's a
good idea I didn't realize that that was
that was what you want to do so that's
what's going on with governor Kevin's
tit and you know I mean listen real
party and now he has coronavirus so
there he is real Patriot being the first
to to take on the corona virus let me
say thank you to Mike tango Bravo who
has signed up on my website join
pakman.com and Ryan Scholl who is new
member number two today also
chang-geun Lim is new member number
three today at join pakman.com I'll say
a little bit more about that coming up a
little bit later
super chats are starting to come in as
we wait for Kaylee McKenna and Annie
Adam White says excited to see today's
dumpster fire I'm gonna go make popcorn
please do Ryan Gill knack says David if
you could voice any cartoon character
who would it be
it's a good question I don't know um who
would I I'd have to think about that I'm
so I don't have any hot take on that Jan
Celt Wasser says keep up the good work
David greetings from Germany you and
your audience proof that u.s. is not
completely lost yet yeah GPB K says New
York City lockdown on March 20 okay all
right so my estimate was close James
Aleppo says I'm worried about not having
results on election night more
Republicans will vote in person his
followers will cry rigging if it takes
days to swing Biden yeah I have a big
story about there's a there's a good
Rolling Stone article by Adam Kroll
about that and I'm going to talk about
it tomorrow
Zachary etzioni says can you please
debate ben shapiro again gladly he's
ignoring me my emails so it's it's up to
him
elias Chavarria says in spanish bordick
in USA video Cinnabun i've thought about
doing spanish videos we went back and
forth
you know there's a lot of different
considerations and things to think about
but you know most of my audience on my
main channel doesn't speak Spanish so
I'd really have to start a new channel
and I'm building it from scratch why
would I do that when this channel is
going so well so there's a lot of
questions around that dan mccords has
welcome back David the longer those
denying the seriousness of the virus the
more it will strongly negatively affect
our country you want to see somebody
denying the seriousness
what's this lunatics name this is
Florida State Rep Anthony Sabatini he's
insisting everything's fine in Florida
Florida has hit three new single day
death records most recently today here
is Anthony Sabatini disgracing the
Sabbatini last name there's this great
argent retired Argentinean tennis player
Gabby Sabatini
and I assume she's cringing when she
sees this take a look exclusively on one
metric namely hold on that's very low
let me let me add a little bit of power
to that here we go cases cases cases
cases the media is almost exclusively
focused on this one number versus the
two most important numbers obviously
hospitalizations and fatalities now
remember deaths are up in Florida there
was a record today there was a record
two days ago
this guy's living in a fantasy world
where in most parts of the States
flatlined or gone down especially in
mine and so if we focus on the two more
relevant metrics in Florida's doing just
fine Ron okay we focus on case
positivity and we just did a report on
the metrics that you cited perhaps you
didn't hear it what a nasty reporter but
you've had actually in Leon County a
circuit judge who said and look we
checked representative we check I
wouldn't be using the term flatlined
when you're talking about a virus and
people dying with constitutional experts
who said and this is what the court
judge said in this this is what the
circuit judge said and constitutional
experts agree with this the ordinance
because you lost in Leon County the
ordinance has a quote valid basis to
protect public health because I mean you
talk about this being an extraordinary
circumstance but we are in an
extraordinary circumstance we're in a
pandemic right and Florida is not doing
just fine
no they are but on the judge issue
there's about 800 Circuit your judge no
you say Florida's doing you think
Florida's doing fine right now it's the
epicenter of the global it's the global
epicenter at this point Miami
specifically could be one of the worst
places in the world to be absolutely I
think the governor's response has been
on point I think yeah that arguably one
of the worst responses in the world from
Governor Ron death Santis as he's
increasingly being known knew the
metrics that matter the most we're doing
very well and if you're counting cases
you're gonna scare people record deaths
my friend what they don't realize this o
case is more or less 4521 total cases
three hundred one thousand last week in
hospitalizations increasing nineteen
thousand three hundred thirty four fifty
four hospital he left to avoid crying I
see use have reached capacity in Florida
another forty hospitals show that I see
us are at 10% or less availability let
me remind you you say you're new a trace
where the were the nation's third
largest state so out of the seventy
thousand new cases we had last week we
had about a hundred more people the
point is the growth rate it's three
records a week if you keep setting
records every single week come on guys
it could is he really that stupid or the
hospital that is a extremely small
number when you're looking at the fact
that we have 21 and a half million
people certainly not the sort of numbers
that would drive people to shut down the
economy pandemic and you can't even
admit that's actually a false assessment
entirely and I don't even know what you
mean by epicenter well that's the
problem they lack the vocabulary to even
discuss what's going on so that's that's
one guy in Florida who is just
incomplete I mean just living in in
make-believe you know pretend everything
so everything's fine we're doing just
fine here let me say thank you to dick
Jackson who has subscribed with twitch
prime and has sent me the message D pag
pogchamp deepak pogchamp d pac pogchamp
d pac pogchamp etc etc i'm not going to
read the entire thing we do have the
belief that this is really going to be
the press briefing at the top of the
hour there was a false start earlier um
let me say thank you to a few folks like
David Lara whose new member number for
today on my website Luis Lopez is new
member number five
Travis Culloden is new member number six
and Lars Henrik Krogh is new member
number seven today on my website I'm
gonna have a secret coupon code for you
guys momentarily a few other super chats
are continuing to come in let me see
where I left off
javi Rodriguez says if a Skoda seat is
vacated before November what BS argument
could McConnell make to fill it without
being a hypocrite it'll he'll be a
hypocrite but he'll fill it that's the
reality when Obama nominated Merrick
garland McConnell said well it's the
president's last year we should wait
until the next person before we fill the
seat now you could make the exact same
argument about Trump but McConnell will
come up with something and of course all
that really matters is if it's a
Republican nominee then Republicans in
the Senate will fill the position if
it's a Democratic nominee then they
won't that's all it is that it's
complete and total hypocrisy
Alex Koepke says do you remember the
time trump scheduled an emergency press
conference to talk trash about joe biden
good times I do remember I do remember
blown high spot says hey David how long
until Trump and company just start
wearing advertisements on their clothes
like NASCAR well I I think they should
in the sense that I would love to know
who is funding them in many cases and
what and what financial motivations
there are for policy that they're
putting out there but no I understand
what you're saying
Elka's says how serious is the
coronavirus for your channel YouTube
channels cannot spread coronavirus
fortunately if you're talking about how
the channel is doing at the beginning of
the virus the YouTube channel was
actually hit pretty hard it's actually
doing well lately and we've been picking
up anywhere from one to looking now one
to four thousand new YouTube subscribers
a day which is absolutely off-the-wall
twitch isn't doing so poorly we
surpassed 38,000
followers there and kind of approaching
40,000 so I think that there's just a
lot of people staying home or out of
their normal routine and initially like
people who normally listen to my podcast
on the way to work they were no longer
going to work so we saw numbers kind of
go down initially as people were out of
their routine we've been in this five
months now so now I think people are
building new routines and the streams
and the clips and the podcasts are part
of it so we're seeing from the
standpoint of audience the last month
has has actually been going really well
Glen bee says greetings from Tasmania
look at how we've crushed the virus
unbelievable stuff there oh my friend
azeema Abu Khalil is here he's been
around the streams for a while does
health organizations encouragement of
BLM protests though infinitely more
legitimate than protests conducted by
trumpets denote hypocrisy or a dangerous
lapse in judgment on their part I don't
I don't know about that here's what I've
said from the beginning the virus
doesn't care why you're protesting the
virus doesn't pick political sides the
virus is a political when you make masks
political you will then start to see a
difference between a protest against
masks and lockdowns where no one is
wearing a mask versus a protest against
police brutality where most people are
wearing masks you'll see a difference
between outdoor events and a rally in
Tulsa Oklahoma where everybody's indoors
with no masks so it's not about politics
it's about the fact that you can find
people without a mask at the at the
police brutality police brutality
protest but most people were wearing
masks that's the difference it's not it
happens to align with pull it with
politics but it is not in any way
political now that being said there were
probably people being hypocritical I'm
sure and I I'm trying not to do that
myself and I don't think I have been
I've been very clear the virus doesn't
care about political ideology the virus
cares about whether you're wearing a
mask
are you outdoors or indoors etc I think
I I think you sort of get the gist Randy
from twitch has subscribed with prime
and says do you think Canada should open
schools
when our daily numbers range from 200 to
400 cases daily as a country of 37
million with deaths of under 20 daily I
I would just go by the health experts
III know what the point you're making
which is Canada as a country is doing
about as well as some of the better
individual states in the United States
it's just I don't want to perpetuate the
idea of people who aren't qualified
giving advice so I would go to the
health experts and I'm actually we have
a Canadian doctor who's been on the show
a bunch of times infectious disease
specialist Isaac BOE gosh from the
University of Toronto hospital or
Medical Center he will be back on soon
and I'll ask him what he thinks you know
it's not it my opinion is irrelevant
quite frankly JR says David how is this
happening bans on masks mandates gorya
beans CDC verges vs. HHS school openings
bouchy bashing like the virus stupidity
and lack of common sense runs rampant
and unchecked in the meantime people are
dying now feels November feels too far
off I agree with you 100% yeah I don't
know if you saw recently Ivanka was
caught holding a can of Goya beans but
actually she was also caught holding my
head which is crazy
can you imagine it's so sick for a
government official to be promoting
alternatives to corporate media like the
David Pakman show and as soon as I saw
that she was doing this we immediately
got authorities involved I offered to
turn myself into federal or or local
authorities and this can't be allowed
she's in a position of power and
privilege and this is just not you
shouldn't see this you really shouldn't
see this this is very very ugly of
course it's not real guys she's not she
didn't sever my head and hold it up I
see people asking whether this is real
real in what sense that's really my face
Bree is this real can you imagine yeah
someone set my head to DC okay we are
standing by for Caylee McKenna knees
press briefing I'm just gonna refresh
once because sometimes the live feed
doesn't get picked up there we go okay I
think we're still doing okay
thanks to Dems Eero cool for subscribing
on Twitch as well as Milky snow and X
Holiday CSX
I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly it
is interesting that the press briefings
and public events seem to be
accelerating you you get the sense that
the Trump administration feels that they
need to do something and they need to be
out there in front of cameras except
every time they do it they do more
self-inflicted damage and so that is
definitely there there they sense that
they need to do something they just keep
doing the wrong things and keep digging
a deeper and deeper hole which is
incredible let me very briefly say that
I so appreciate everybody who's been
signing up on my website for the last
few days in early July we had 300
membership cancellations it was a big
hole that we had to start digging out of
and it's because of coronavirus I had
dozens of people email me and say David
I signed up in july 2019 I should be
renewing I just can't afford it
essentially was was the message and I am
completely sympathetic to that so I
really appreciate that folks have been
signing up and we're the streams this
podcast it's all going to continue but
there's a lot of folks who are having to
bail on supporting us and I totally get
that so if you're in a position where
you can grab a membership at join
pakman.com I very much appreciate it and
I have a very special announcement I
know I've been mentioning this code
20/20 now which is a beautiful discount
off of memberships I'm gonna give you
right now a different discount code this
is this is a secret discount code okay
the code is July surprise
July surprise use that code it's not
printed anywhere you just have to
understand how to spell these two words
July's surprise with no space you will
get an even more surprising discount off
of any membership at join pakman.com and
I'll thank people who sign up like for
example day lists TiVo's Dallas T voz
man I don't know your new member number
8 Lee Cole
is new member number 9 Ben Isaacson is
new member number 10 Jenny sent st.
Clair is new member number 11 and Mike
Moyer is number 12 and I actually I've
got Daniel Grabowski at number 13 and
Ryan Gill knack at number 14 a July
surprise is the coupon code and it is
this coupon code let me put it this way
this guy right here
governor Kevin's tit he was stupid
enough to brag about being at
restaurants during coronavirus when
other states were shut down now he has
the virus even Kevin's tit would be
smart enough to realize July surprise is
just I mean it's it's unconscionable
it's not conscionable what am I talking
about by the way okay let's go to some
other super chats coming in david Belski
says please don't ever again title one
of your videos trump collapses unless he
literally physically collapses that I'd
want to see see I don't agree with that
I don't I don't want anybody to get
coronavirus I don't want anybody to get
sick I don't I just want Trump to lose
and I want to deal with coronavirus I
don't need Trump to get physically ill I
do I'd never wish that on anybody the
luck hunter says come to your show from
our vineyard in Mendoza you can get in
here at least talk wine crypto and cover
the election so as some of you know I
was born in Argentina and I was born in
the city of Buenos Aires the capital of
Argentina but last summer
no the summer before when I was down
visiting family in Buenos Aires I took a
side trip to Mendoza Mendoza is a
fantastic wine region of Argentina sort
of in the foothills of the Andes rented
a car went to a bunch of different
vineyards had some amazing wine lunches
including at just a bunch of different
amazing amazing places went to to
Francis mall Minh restaurants in Mendoza
1884 is one that is just incredible
incredible restaurant also went to Oda
igano
or oregano as we would say in in the
United States another restaurant of
Francis Mullins and it's just an amazing
place I would love to be back in Mendoza
now that being said Argentina's not
doing so great as far as the virus goes
although I think most of the problem is
in the bueno situs area including the
province Mendoza
not not only that there's no flights
down to Argentina right as Lord buck
bucket face is pointing out I am a
citizen of Argentina although my
passport currently is expired but you
know when I go in I have a US passport
that says born in Argentina and I can go
in the local passport line so I my
instinct is I would be allowed into the
country if I could get a flight down
there yeah so that's uh that's that's
something you know that we have to look
at ok John easy Irish but by the way
luck hunters please get in touch with me
by email because if you do have a
vineyard down in Mendoza next time
whenever the next time is that I'm down
there I would love to visit your
vineyard I've visited five or six
vineyards in the area and it's it's a
magical place the views of the Andes I
have pictures on my Instagram of it and
it's it's gonna be great someday someday
Dan McCord says no one is talking about
the fact that over 99% of the US
population has yet to get kovat 19 or
Trump Kobe 20 as some of us are calling
it this is just the beginning it is just
the beginning that's true
welcome if you're just joining us we are
eight minutes late we're actually 68
minutes late this was originally
scheduled for 1:00 p.m. Eastern Time
10:00 a.m. Pacific
it was then delayed by an hour and we
are now another eight minutes late and
my senses there may not be that much
news broken there may not be that much
news broken but if you are just joining
I do appreciate everybody who's been
watching the streams remember that if
you're watching on youtube you can hit
that subscribe button it costs it costs
absolutely nothing I consider it a
privilege every time somebody subscribes
watching on twitch you can also hit the
follow button to be notified of future
disinformation propaganda streams Karen
says hello from Ireland David right now
myself and other Europeans are separated
from our loved ones I haven't seen my
husband in seven months waiting on a
visa your streams help me know what's
going on
thank you Karen odd that doesn't sound
like a good situation but I appreciate
the kind words Jason the ex says
Kayleigh here's a key word she
immediately goes to the binder and
frantically searches for her talking
point she's just a parrot title is
misspelled the title of why the title
for this stream is that right let me see
update titles Trump press secretary oh
my goodness it is misspelled let me fix
that that is embarrassing
Kaley make any urgent press briefing let
me update okay we have updated that and
let's see okay twitch is updated
hopefully YouTube is uploaded as updated
as well
we were probably missing out on some
viewers who saw her name misspelled and
furiously chose you know like the fox
news stream or something like that if
you can imagine okay a blown high spot
has subscribed on YouTube other super
chats are coming in where did I leave
off here where are we oh my goodness
that klav Miller says do you have an
opinion on the UK's coronavirus response
I really don't you know I've only
closely been following the response in
the US and the response in Argentina
really so I I don't I think there's
people who are much better positioned to
comment on the UK response than I am
parity Wren says Kaler is a ballbuster
especially pompous ones love it hardcore
FPS says you make me moist oh my
goodness things are getting very very
racy in the chat Zachary pre Kowski says
title typo okay we fixed it Green Party
Trevor says urgent why don't
you raid other twitch streamers when
you're done streaming also hope you make
an official discord server so there's an
unofficial discord server I'm probably
not gonna get too involved in discord at
this time we do have an official
subreddit david pakman.com slash read it
and i should do more rating you know
that a lot of the issue is that let me
see
most of the people I follow aren't
streaming when I wrap up my streams
let's see who's streaming right now that
I follow that we could maybe raving out
oh my god
things are starting to play let me see
here who could we raid today Hasan
destiny [ __ ] ii is streaming right now
Steven Kenneth destiny bonel ii is
streaming right now and sam cedar is
streaming of the people that i follow
that's really it right now yeah we could
do i could potentially look at rating
one of them i'll look at that and we'll
have an answer for you on that soon
something I could do
yeah I should raid Hasan I'm worried
that Hasan may not be super pleased with
me because actually I don't know why but
a few weeks ago when I was streaming I
reached out to him and I said hey let's
like you know let's let's do do a thing
and he didn't even write back which was
it was it was shade so I hope things are
ok with her son I've not taken any side
on Hasan versus destiny and I don't plan
to but yeah maybe we'll do a little a
little Hassan raiding action after
today's stream Sharpie diesel says did
you see my question in the last chat
about the floods why is no one reporting
I didn't see it no I'll look into that
I'll look into them Waller is me says I
predict cases and death numbers slowly
going down and any states crying foul
will be quote Democrat states who can be
denounced as fake news any effect on the
election if Trump is able to control
numbers well that's the goal they now
are they now are taking control of the
data and the data really both and I I
expect that we will be increasingly
unable to trust the numbers that we're
getting as if we were already able as if
we could trust them already you know
Florida was caught hiding numbers months
ago
makes the Gary Cunningham and my
thriving treehouse for signing up Matt
Chavez says register and vote Biden do
not become complacent t love says have
you ever thought about being on CNN I
would love to watch you there I actually
have been on CNN see if I can find it I
was on with Erin Burnett David Pakman
Erin Burnett let's see if I can find it
I'm actually having trouble finding the
clip that's interesting I think it might
be on my own website david pakman.com
slash press maybe um CNN hmm I don't
even remember what year it was it was a
long time I'm not really like you know
ripe for CNN necessarily but I have been
on before I'm actually I think I was on
a couple times on CNN but I'm struggling
to find it let me say ah here it is let
me see here actually I don't even know
if they have the video up still let's
take a look this was my big CNN
appearance see here no it doesn't look
like my video is still even here yeah
I'm gonna have to look around for that I
think it may be I don't think I'm in
this video let me say oh no this this is
something totally different yeah I've
been on CNN anyway I'll look for that
maybe I'll have that for an upcoming
stream but I have been on CNN I've been
on Fox I've never been I think I've
never been on MSNBC if I recall
correctly David Adom says Georgia
governor overruled city and county mask
requirements yes so some Georgia's out
of control completely out of control and
I'm starting to see Georgia cities and
towns put in place mask mandates and
Brian Kemp the completely disgusting
depraved delusional and doofy a little
alliteration there Georgia governor he
is saying all
masks mandates are null and void and you
know people will die because of that
there's no doubt about it
somebody is going to die as a result of
that Sebastian bula says what do you
think about the Patriots playing games
with one fifth capacity would you go you
know I'm basically done with the phase
in my life where I go to in-person
sporting events it's just a [ __ ] show I
don't want to sit in traffic on the way
there I don't want to sit in traffic on
the way back I don't want you know some
somebody's knees on my back I don't want
people spilling beer on me I just I I
have a better view from home so I have
no plan to go to a Patriots game whether
it's one fifth capacity or 6/5 capacity
or whatever I'll watch on TV I'll have
my grille I'll have you know all of that
stuff I'll have my allagash whites and
all of that and I just don't I I do it
with one fifth capacity do it with
nobody I don't care how about if I have
at it Hoss is my point of view gr says
DZ y you don't buy me Reeboks no more oh
boy I hope that user is not having a
medical incident semi-truck driver says
any thoughts on the Republican Party
having their convention outdoors in
Jacksonville Florida August heat seems
like a bad idea it all seems like a bad
idea it seems like a disastrous idea
Eric Foreman says I can't believe were
arguing science in 2020 it's insane yeah
it is what it is let me say thank you to
AC war Singh missing tie charlie poo
axon quill Aryan all of whom have signed
up with twitch prime or real twitch
subscriptions at twitch.tv slash David
Pakman we're standing by for Kaylee
magon Annie
it is now one hour and 17 minutes past
when this was originally scheduled
originally scheduled for 1 p.m. Eastern
rescheduled for 2 p.m. Eastern and it's
now 2:18 p.m. Eastern now I'm getting a
bunch of text messages I wonder if it's
been rescheduled nothing so far it looks
like we're still on track here
but does anybody know if there's a
stream that have is an urgent press
briefing delayed eighty ninety minutes
almost is anybody live in the room right
now does anybody know if like maybe now
this or Washington Post or somebody is
live in the room cuz that usually gives
us a sense of how close we are to the
start of it let me see here not seeing
anything in the immediate oh you see
reporters in there so tell me can
somebody tell me which stream is
currently showing a live shot of the
room now this news okay now this press
briefing let's get a better better shot
for you guys I want to bring you the
best possible shot difference between
what you I'm just getting crazy I think
I've almost got it there it is we may
just have to sit through a brief ad yeah
and we'll just just a few seconds
that'll be good I think once we see
what's happening in the room we'll be
able to very clearly tell how close we
are to the start of this and here we go
oh this is a different shot than I'm
used to it looks like the room is
relatively full so they probably are
going to start somewhat soon yeah this
is good we'll stick with this for the
time being that's good welcome to the
ten thousand of you that are watching on
YouTube the 1,000 of you watching on
Twitch the 1,200 of you watching on
Facebook and I never know how many
people are watching this on Twitter just
out of curiosity let me take a look it's
usually not good twitter does not like
these press briefings 78 of you okay how
do we have 10,000 viewers on YouTube and
78 on Twitter that seems out of sync
that's interesting
super chats continue to come in Madeline
Welsh says David I know you've talked
about Linda Sarsour before but I would
love one of your longer analysis videos
about anti-semitism and progressive
media because there seems to be a blind
spot yeah you know to be totally
transparent it's like I've dealt with
left-wing anti-semitism before and my
audience doesn't really seem to love it
and it often divides
my audience and I just don't know to
what degree it makes sense for me to be
harping on that but yeah I mean it's not
it's a topic that's interesting to me
for sure and heck says see s Bachman DNA
gets aired we know if it's pakman it
must be good yes reminiscent of Ivanka's
tweet with a can of Goya beans which has
been modified to have her manipulating
my cranium as you can see here yeah if
it's packed that I like that that's a
that's a beautiful sentiment
Giovanni Trumbo says please don't pause
or mute the feed to talk okay
let's let's talk about that a little bit
okay there are countless streams where
people can watch these press briefings
this is that now this stream okay this
is the Fox News stream this is the White
House stream so my thing is when
something outrageous is said during
these events I will mute and I will talk
over it and every time it happens a few
people don't like it and there's plenty
of other streams for people to watch
right if I'm just gonna sit here totally
silently
there's no way to fact-check everything
after the fact what am I really adding
I'm adding nothing I'm not I'm not
pulling myself up by the bootstraps and
creating any value so if you want to
watch with me that's great but I might
interject every once in a while there's
no shortage of places you can watch if
you want me to just quiet the entire
time so want me to sit quietly the
entire time so that's my disclaimer as
far as that goes
okay Michael a sense of super chat Troy
Baker says should President Biden create
a Department of Technology maybe yang
for secretary I am NOT putting the cart
before the horse on anything with Biden
okay first Biden's got a win then we'll
figure out what departments Joe Biden
needs to create that's that's my that's
my idea dak dak says what's the
significance of the Republican Party
registering a record number of
Republican voters also have you seen the
report from the Shady GA eye about voter
rhod I have not listened both parties
are registering a lot of people will see
who registers more we're gonna find out
very very soon Syed Ahmad says whoops
that scrolled past where did that go do
you think Donald Trump that do you think
a Donald Trump that was checked when he
was younger and actually suffered
consequences would have led to a more
humble less crazy person yes it's
revisionist history I know but curious
what you think for sure I mean Trump
Trump you know especially the
allegations made in Mary Trump's book
much of trumps personality is perfectly
in line with the allegations that she
makes about Trump's upbringing and the
verbal abuse and the seeing his dad
never apologized to anyone for anything
etc etc so that uh yeah I mean I I think
that that's that's absolutely the case
drew by OD Biswas says hi from India
keep up the good work love your content
we are in the same sinking boat in terms
of national politics best of luck
yeah India Brazil Russia also along with
the US and major major trouble big
trouble
Phoenix 5:03 says the trump presidency
presidency should be used as an example
when explaining the importance of voting
hit the like button for David love the
show yeah what we have 11,000 viewers on
YouTube and only 1100 likes that's
that's really low-energy I don't like
that I do want to say thanks to Stephen
6:27 for subscribing with twitch prime
dattebayo has subscribed with prime
hourglass 420 and trauma 'kiss have
subscribed with prime Pittsburgh handy
and would eeks have subscribed with
prime which I very much appreciate John
Coley says aside from the State of the
Union when do presidents feel the need
to convince us they're doing a good job
it should be obvious well I mean
campaigns right any every reelection
campaign the president has to make the
case that they deserve another four
years a fox Johnson says wasn't this
their tactic last election just
keep talking and see what sticks to a
degree 2 degree Sean em says David are
you big ly philanthropic you know I
don't really talk too much about my
philanthropy both in terms of dollars
and volunteer time because I find it to
be much like the Bible is for Trump I
find it's a a very personal thing but
I'm actually being serious
whereas Trump just doesn't know anything
about the Bible Luis Lopez says thanks
for being a truthful news outlet for us
all give a shout out to Jennifer for me
Jennifer you are being shouted out thank
you so much
Peretz here and says I guess McKenna MA
holds 67 SEC get questions for
frantically go through her binder and
find some non releve 'td answers you
know I want to explore pairs our good
friend from Sweden and I never know
whether he is using some kind of
translation tool let's just see what
happens from Swedish if I go to
translate google.com if I type that in
that's English if I translate that to
Swedish let's just see what we get and
then I'm gonna translate it back okay
translate to Swedish okay now I'm gonna
take all this how do I copy this oh
there we go
oh my god huge copy and paste problems
here there we go okay so now we're going
to reverse okay I don't know what's
going it's not working but it sounds
like something is starting here right ah
we're back in the room here that didn't
work okay we're in the room we're gonna
abandon that idea but pare I love it I
don't know what you're talking about but
you're a genius my friend and I so
appreciate your support
John North says David just thanks for
what you do Dream Hollow says even if
Crump's administration alters the
numbers States will still be reporting
on ICU capacity and death toll he can't
hide that
that's exactly my hope that's exactly my
hope Adam White says dang it finished my
popcorn guess I need a spread maybe I'll
break out some bagels and lox home made
of course homemade locks are homemade
bagels I would love to be smoking salmon
at home
that seems actually like a good like a
good coronavirus project for me smoking
some salmon Salman as some people call
it thanks to Lambeau and Jack Attack as
well as sudden echo for the twitch
subscription sudden echo says I've been
looking into Southern Strategy out of
curiosity is there any merit to the idea
well I don't know what you mean by merit
I mean it's a real thing and it's a way
to appeal to certain voters maybe maybe
I'll do like a little history of
Southern Strategy at some point it's an
interesting concept
Scott forgot says David have we become
the [ __ ] country now basically yeah
I mean we are now the disease the
disease caring foreigners that other
countries don't want
I mean it's depressing it's incredibly
depressing but uh that's it's the
unfortunate reality
Jacob price says South Carolina Governor
McMaster just announced school will
resume in September okay John Coley says
in an attempt to hear both sides who is
David Pakman conservative equal in terms
of intelligence and likability I have no
idea that would be more for the audience
to decide I think thanks to Vaknin
California for the twitch Prime
subscription Gregory's shaver's jr. says
you should interview Peter Zayin on your
show don't know who that is but I'll
check it out evan field says ladies and
gentlemen propaganda Barbie I call her
evil Christian Barbie I find that more
precise parity run says I say as monty
python get on with it
Wow Juran Neitzel says amazing
adventures await you do your part hit
the like button jr. says CNN piece was
on April 14th 2014 Kansas suspect okay
yeah I want to find my old CNN
appearance to play for people and I will
do that nasty question says I want to
hear your whoa that just scrolled away
where did
go nasty questions said I want to hear
your commentary continue to interject
please I will thank you I appreciate the
support onder's foster says I know it's
a little late but do you have any
thoughts on the Dave Chappelle 846
special I didn't see it
I barely watch any stand-up comedy and
especially lately I've just had such
little time to watch anything Millicent
says is this going to be another
emergency campaign speech like the other
day give us back info from the CDC I
don't know what to expect yeah this was
supposedly a really important press
briefing scheduled for 1:00 p.m. Eastern
they rescheduled it for 2 p.m. Eastern
it's now 2:30 p.m. Eastern no respect
for the press no respect for the
audience no respect for the American
people it's just no respect it's it's
unbelievable and we may act now that we
have a wider shot we may still have a
ways to go that the room is not totally
full yet with report reporters even
accounting for the chairs that are
blocked off urgent urgent that this take
place
urgent that they speak truth to power to
the American people they're running an
hour and a half behind but it's urgent
don't forget very very urgent thanks to
Michael for the super chat Safra geum
says the only way i can listen to these
press conferences is through your stream
keep up the great coverage oh speaking
of which I saw somebody mentioned Jimmy
from Philly there's this furious furious
trumpet who just leaves message after
message after message he called in again
recently and I know some of you have
been asking whether he's ok I'll just
just because we have a little time I'll
play a couple of these voicemails from
you take up too late let's take a listen
here we go
hello everyone this afternoon President
Trump will deliver remarks on rolling
back regulations to help all Americans
deregulation has been a top priority
it's already aeneas the president
reversed the disastrous over-regulation
of the obama-biden administration give
us the list under President Trump seven
deregulatory actions have been taken for
everyone new regulation million dollars
in regulatory cost savings and it is
important to note that this deregulation
deregulation agenda lowers the cost for
every American that was causing these
burdensome regulations fall
disproportionately and benefit
disproportionately lower-income
Americans wrong so this president took
action to roll back the burdensome
regulations that harm low-income
communities remember deregulation
disproportionately hurts low-income
communities who are downwind from
pollution etc I'm sure you know the
regulatory agenda will boost household
and income by $3,100 annually no way
thanks to president Trump's rolling back
Biden era cafe standards family families
will have access to cheaper cars the
president's health care deregulation
will also save patients nearly 10
percent on prescription drug costs while
he's real wins for the American people
will disappear with a reregulate agenda
which is why President Trump will
continue to pursue his historic
deregulation activity on another note we
saw encouraging news yesterday on
vaccines moderna vaccine candidate is
showing promising signs it produced a
positive neutral immune response among
the 45 participant like zero to do with
Trump since and the bottom line is that
so far we are seeing exactly what you
would hope to see in a vaccine i they're
expected the moderna vaccine in
particular is expected to reach phase
three by late July with 30 thousand
participants and great finally on the
therapeutics front I just want to note
very encouraging Regeneron contract a
450 million dollar contract for
monoclonal antibody cocktail fantastic
has nothing to do with Trump either end
of convalescent plasma
one of the several therapeutics
available to treat Ovid can be used for
prophylaxis and treatment and they say
they could have up to 70 to 300,000 dose
vials of this by the end of the summer
or early fall so operation warp-speed
continues we continue to see none of
this has anything to do with operation
warp speed please don't forget that
thank you
Maryland governor Larry Hogan said today
that President Trump has left States to
fend for themselves during this pandemic
he accused the president of not
listening to medical experts that is
quite a takedown coming out of a
Republican gun yeah it's really striking
on his comments especially when you
compare them to his past comment this is
revisionist history by Governor Hogan
and it's a stark contrast the
revisionist history is that from handled
this properly in January a communication
that the president has had with
governor's on March 19th he also said
thank you there's been tremendous
cooperation and what is so striking to
me about reading that op-ed is that this
dramatic April 18th scene where South
Korea delivered tests but just the day
prior he said something entirely
different he in fact thanked the
president for the progress we've seen in
federal and state coordination in recent
weeks and went on to praise to anybody
else sick of the performative nature of
these events the states including
ventilators and testing capabilities so
24 hours before this dramatic opening
scene of his op-ed he literally was
praising the president the United States
for delivering on testing how do you
explain the president trumpet is
trailing his opponent by double digits
both nationally and in battleground Nats
with majorities disapproving of his
handling of race relations and the
so that would be a question for the
campaign when it comes to campaign
polling but what I would say is we
believe this president has great
approval on this country his historic Co
video response speaks for itself with
delivering on ventilators and stores in
the world in the amount of testing we've
provided therapeutics the 13 vaccine
candidates the moderna the 13 vaccine
candidates have nothing to do with Trump
that's really them eventually we're
gonna get a cure of a vaccine something
eventually right the question is will
have Trump accelerated it slowed it down
or done nothing yeah we've seen that
doesn't hold a range of public events
this week but none of those events have
been focused on the corona virus why not
the president routinely focused on the
corona virus I think he'll be hearing
more about what we're doing in the
coming week he's hard at work we talk
about kovat every day from this podium
the task force is hard at work and I'm
glad you asked about kovin in particular
just wait there read through some of the
things that we are doing yeah which i
think is most most important than what
we're saying is what we're doing and the
White House has engaged and traveled dr.
Burks on to Louisiana Mississippi
Alabama Georgia you know the way we're
dealing with coronavirus is by flying a
doctor all around the country an
individual doctor tomorrow HHS has
deployed 19 teams across the country we
identify not where we see mbers but pre
that we identify where we might see an
emergence and we send teams there to
address it in advance so we're proactive
the dr. Burke's routine they're calling
Florida embers it's like every day
they're setting a case in death record
Sean rammed a severe we've surged it to
Texas Florida California Arizona 65,000
vials went to these four states and
we're also a surging testing site so
we're doing stuff each and every day
really surely you'd agree this is the
biggest challenge facing the public
right now why aren't we seeing it as the
president's biggest public priority the
president's focusing on alone that
president just yesterday how to a big
press conference if you will or in a
veil on the Opel Oval Office about ms-13
is something that we're focused on it is
a top priority of this administration
how many people did ms-13 kill versus
how many people did coronavirus kill but
there are other things the president has
to focus on namely Democrat City's not
controlling their streets namely the
mayor of Chicago people dying in her in
her on the streets of her city every
weekend and the president sent her a
letter saying you must secure your city
the president's involved an operation
legend in honor of legend Tala Farah a
young man I don't think this is
resonating I think the public knows what
the issues are and that's the reason
Trump's losing by double digits I don't
think her coming out and saying ms-13 is
actually gonna redirect people's
attention he killed those two young
little girls and he's held their killer
accountable the leader of that ring so
the president's focused on Co but it's a
top priority he's focused on the
violence in the streets he's doing a lot
of things at once and that's the great
thing about the Trump administration
what's the last time he attended a Task
Force briefing the president is briefed
on coronavirus each and every day yes
darling
does the White House agree that it's not
helpful for people to wait 7 days or
longer to get the results on therap
karana virus tests and this and it's the
White House going to do anything to try
to shorten those wait time so that
people can get their results sooner so
we've done more than any country in the
world on testing the question is what
can you do to shorten wait times from 7
days 7 days even in Massachusetts where
we're doing well 5 to 7 days before you
know your results longer to process than
others but we have surged testing to the
States and we encourage them to use it
to their best ability and to process
those tests as quickly as possible not
just about the quantity of testing about
the quality is the administration doing
any
to make all the test out there with your
clicker results you know a lot of health
experts are worried that when people
have to wait seven days are longer there
they're out you know spreading the
disease unknowingly so as I noted there
are several different types of tests
there's the Abbott rapid response test
there are other tests that take longer
dr. Burks and Admiral's wha are
constantly out there advising on testing
and how to process these remember of
course the trick is the machine might
take 15 minutes to give you the results
from one test but you could have a seven
day backlog because you can only do four
tests an hour per machine very very
deceptive but it's it's cheap deception
we can see through it
52 sites testing in America in 48 states
and the District of Columbia 65 percent
of these sites are located in counties
with moderate to high social
vulnerability and 201 additional sites
will be going live this week and that's
on top of the 1,300 federally qualified
it feels like we're back in March where
they talk about the number of testing
sites versus the number of tests that
can actually be processed more weight
people are killed as an answer to why
black people are still being killed by
police officers but by population
percentages black people are about three
times more likely than
people to die in a police encounter if
the president won't even acknowledge
that how can he fix the Pope he won't he
said the president has routinely
acknowledged and expressed the absolute
atrocity of the case of George Floyd and
his heart goes out to that family still
he was noting a fact that there were
when you look at unarmed killings with
police interactions in this country that
you had nine unarmed black individuals
who were fatally shot in 19 unarmed
white individuals that's down from 38
and 32 respectively in 2015 so the
numbers have actually come down since
the Obama administration he was making
that point but one point he wants to
strongly make is this that black men and
women who die of homicide they are
likely to die of homicide at eight times
greater than that of white individuals
and Hispanics combined that that's the
rate combined so that's an extraordinary
thing that we want to look at I've
listed for you the names of these kids
who have died across this country it is
unacceptable and under this president
he'll take action in the derelict mayor
of Chicago should step up and ask for
federal help because she's doing a very
poor job at securing her
the u.s. is concerned about escalation
of so I have no announcements on that
front but rest assured we keep every
option on the table with regard to China
he's not ruled out any options with
regard to China thanks Kaylee does the
White House have a reaction to the
hacking of Twitter last night and you
have any broader concerns or does the
president have any broader concerns
about using that platform to issue not
only his own opinions but official
policy pronouncements given it's
apparently vulnerability to hacking
right yeah so I spoke with Dan scavino
before coming out here my team did dance
Covino who twit tweeted a meme of doctor
foul Qi as dr. faucet 18 hours to keep
Twitter secure the president's twitter
feed the president will remain on
twitter but his account was secure and
not jeopardized during these attacks
okay and just one follow-up to regis
question i guess i didn't follow the
data that you were just referring to are
you saying that the president did have
to back up his claim that more white
people are killed by police officers
that black people yeah I've already read
out that data to you I think we followed
it I did already right off that date
it's you and you can go back Jack I'm
sorry Jeff you're not smart enough to
understand her facts with three felonies
in a voter fraud case I that's the first
time hearing of that I haven't spoken to
the president of it he does have very
real concerns about voter fraud we're
not firm and he's mentioned several of
those and there's yet more information
that there is rampant voter fraud when
you have mass mail-in voting not 20 so
you don't has noted about 1% remember
you have an absentee ballot process
which we want to expand to everybody
they are pretending or believe that
absentee ballots and mail-in voting in
the US or two different things we're
just talking about expanding absentee
it's out of New Jersey have found a US
Postal Service vehicle that may have
been carrying mail in ballots that were
that was caught on fire this attack
their example is that there was an
incidental fire of a vehicle that's the
example can you imagine publicans
receive ballots with all Democrat
candidates that's like saying you
shouldn't ship vials of blood to be
tested because once a FedEx vehicle
caught on fire it's like that's not
about the integrity of the samples there
was a fire to dog catcher and these were
supposed to be Republican ballots those
are three recent examples and there are
many more quick quick second questions
when the president made the initial
Republic national conventions from
Charlotte to Florida he said that it was
because the North Carolina governor was
in a shutdown mood and that he was
playing politics because we did not a
pack an indoor stadium to full capacity
we also said that the cost to North
Carolinians would be in according the
president now all of the jobs and
economic development the cotton the
convention would bring to all of that
money all of that time all of that cost
to jobs and economic development to
North Carolinians for the same result
because the convention in Florida what
does the person have to say that North
Carolinians president loves the people
of North Carolina they're well aware of
that the president wanted to be able to
hold his convention which is why it was
moved to Jacksonville and for anything
further I'd refer you to the RNC yes
Thank You Kerry the president has talked
about an executive order on immigration
coming soon he's also talked about
protections for daca recipients it's
been unclear though whether those
protections the path to citizenship that
the president talked about will be
included in the executive order so
something here to clarify will the path
to citizenship protections for going to
be part of the executive order so what I
would say is this as the president
announced he's working on an executive
order to establish a merit-based
immigration system that will be the
intent of the executive order but the
president has long said that he would
look for a legislative solution on daca
and he would work with Congress got
three and a half months my friend and I
and one that could include citizen
citizenship along with other strong
border security and permanent
merit-based reforms so that is something
he would work with Congress on yeah and
the executive order would pertain to the
merit-based portion of that a second
question on the schools
the president the vice president talked
about some of the guy new guidelines or
new pages of documents for CDC coming
out this week is that still the plan are
those going to come out this week is
there any chance that this is being
rethought at this time so those are CDC
guidelines you're referencing so I'll
leave it I'll leave it to CDC as to
windows guidelines come out but we
really want you winding up to a scripted
walk off clear we don't think our
children should be locked up at home
with devastating consequences when it's
perfectly safe for them to go to school
as emphasized by many medical experts so
the president is very keen on seeing
schools reopen and we the only thing
that's fair to America's children yes
thanks Haley two quick questions for you
on Wednesday the CDC director said quote
if all of us would put on a face
covering now for the next four weeks six
weeks I think we could drive this
epidemic into the ground
Admiral Joe our girar has made similar
comments the CDC director called it our
quote major defense I'm wondering if the
president would consider at any point I
a nationwide mathematic well the
president has said that he would wear a
mask if he was in a place where he
couldn't be appropriately social
distanced he do question is can trump
come out and say my fellow Americans we
have an unprecedented crisis on our
hands I need every one of you to take
this seriously and where am at right
that's what well how many lives would be
saved if Trump had done that coverings
and the CDC guidelines remain the same
today recommended but not required
second question for you we're saying
earlier the president is very concerned
about local
officials who are not thinking actions
about you know deaths in their cities
you also said he was appalled by what
happened to George Floyd in March a 26
year old black woman named Brianna
Taylor was killed while sleeping in her
home the three officers involved in that
case in Kentucky have not been arrested
or fired is the president monitoring
that case at all and does every want to
see justice for Barrowman Allen
okay well way into that other than to
say I'd refer you to the DOJ who takes
federal action more necessary where the
facts grieve for China which is this guy
right feel like his questions are always
pretty extreme Thank You Leah I did see
your question earlier and I brought it
to the president and he said I love the
people of India and I love the people of
China everything possible to keep the
peace for the people real political
genius yes question two flows from two
events that we saw recently that we
wouldn't have seen at previous White
House's the first was the campaign
meeting in the cabinet grown last month
and then the political speech in the
Rose Garden
can you talk about your understanding of
what the White House policy is for this
White House as far as politics is there
anyplace in the White House where you
think politics is inappropriate where
you know where do you draw the line we
act in accordance with the Hatch Act
it's well established that the President
and Vice President are not subject to
the Hatch Act it says this much in the
Hatch Act it says that the Hatch Act
applies to executive branch employees
which is defined in the Hatch Act as
employee meaning any individual other
than the president and the
vice-president so the white house sacred
where you just heard the President and
Donna candidate speech from the Rose
Garden well we talked about earlier with
school districts but we're seeing more
school districts at least in Virginia
for example last night decided to go
online only what does the president say
the parents are going ok what do I do
with my kids the president has said
unmistakeably that he wants schools to
open and I was just in the Oval talking
him about that and when he says open he
means open and full kids being able to
attend each and every day at their
Bailey's walk off today is gonna be
making her her family's refried bean
recipe from some cans of Goya beans this
was a good quote of course we can do it
everyone else in the Western world our
pure nations are doing it
we are the outlier here the science is
very clear on this that you know for
instance you look at the JAMA pediatric
study of 46 pediatric hospitals in North
America that said the risk of critical
illness from Kovac is far less for
children the night of seasonal flu the
science is on our side here and we
encourage for localities and states to
just simply follow the science opener
all of these people deserve to never
work again when it's all done like she
should be unhireable anywhere after what
she's been doing for this administration
address when students are not in school
our schools are extremely important
they're essential and they must reopen
yeah
thanks daily US Canada UK today excuse
from Russia trying to have her on the
virus research vaccine research I was
wondering if the president has a
response to Russia today yes so the one
thing I would say about that and it was
made it was announced earlier today is
that we worked very closely with our
allies to ensure that we would take
measures to keep that information safe
when we continue to do so we're aware of
those activities yes CDC on a movement
of data going straight from CDC to the
photographer understanding that HHS
needs access to real-time data was there
also any concern whatsoever under during
this decision under guard great they're
going out of Florida certain states were
coming out and saying mid-level CDC
reports we're not necessarily we prefer
to listen back you know the intent for
this decision and I talked extensively
today with dr. Burks with secretary azar
and with dr. Redfield about this the
intent of this is we need to make sure
that there is daily data that is being
given to dr. Burks and others who are
running point yeah on a lot of our
actions with from jessa fear and I don't
worry guys dr. Burks now will decide
what data gets published it's gonna be
fine and in the press that there are two
methods of data collection the one is
the national healthcare safety Network
and this is a CDC system and this is
where hospitals voluntarily report their
data and about 81 percent of hospitals
we're reporting their data so we don't
need 81 percent of hospitals reporting
data we need 100 percent of hospitals
reporting data because it is critical
that dr. Burks and others receive the
daily admissions ICU use and PPE numbers
and when you're only getting 81 percent
of hospital data that means you've got
19 percent of hospitals that were
unaware of their needs so what happened
is we also go with the walk of using of
tracking this data and it's the
hello tracker database and this is an
HHS system and this was initially used
for purposes of provider relief funding
and we asked hospitals to tell us about
their kovat admissions so that we could
identify possible hotspots and as it
turns out this data ended up being more
complete more up-to-date with
information and so ensuring that
hospitals are reporting into this system
where we're getting more complete data
was the reason that HHS and would that
I'll leave you to think about how you've
been very bad boys and girls today
according to the tell attractor tell a
tracker system it's important especially
with REM desapeared distribution that we
know exactly where the needs are so we
can surge them so this data yes that's
right so I I did confirm that with dr.
Redfield but this is completely open
source data available to the CDC
secretary a czar says we insist that
they use it and no one and dr. Redfield
confirm this no one is taking access or
data away from the CDC and that data is
routinely published so that the American
people are I believe it true yeah yes so
I wanted to follow on that briefly
there's been some complaints
particularly among independent modelers
who are using the CDC data that was
updated
to sort of put out their public models
some of which the White House's relied
on that now those dashboards have been
taken down so I'm wondering if the
administration would sort of commit to
making the broader database a bit more
available to the public
the CDC database is the public data
that's been out there it'll continue to
be public it should be public and this
is all about getting more data out there
not less data and ensuring in particular
that our doctors get that daily data and
one thing that I'd also like to point
out for everyone it's just with regard
to testing we've done more than 42
months is the walk noted the second
highest number is 12 million from India
we're leading the world in testing it's
a very stark contrast and the president
mentioned this yesterday so I just
wanted to put some some additional
information out there was actually CBS
reporting that in 2009 under Obama Biden
quotes and this is CBS reporting CDC
abruptly advised States to stop testing
for h1n1 flu and stopped counting
individual cases so while this
president's surge testing under the
Obama administration squarely in Ron
Klain Vice President Biden's former
chief of staff said this it is purely a
fortuity that h1n1 isn't one of the
great mass casualty events in American
history nothing to do with us doing
anything right this is former VP Biden's
chief of staff it just had to do with
luck contrary to that this president led
the world in testing led the world and
ventilators redistributing ventilators
for therapeutics 13 vaccine candidates
one going into phase three clinical
trial this response has been
extraordinary and historic we didn't
pause testing the obama-biden
administration did and that was a
shameful decision thank you there's the
walk up so let me explain that there
they're now picking up on this h1n1
thing so what they're saying now is
Obama and Biden stopped testing for h1n1
understand that h1n1 ended up being not
very deadly and so widespread that there
was no point in testing for it in the
sense that it was being treated like the
flu
started being given Tamiflu when they
tested positive early there was no
reason to test because you weren't
trying to you weren't dealing with it
any differently than the seasonal flu of
that year in fact I remember I was in
Argentina at the time my brother got
h1n1 at the time when they were still
testing and then other people in our
family got sick testings there was no
point to testing at a certain point
because it had just gone completely but
with what she's essentially saying is
that they are almost saying it doesn't
really matter if we test because we're
conceding everybody's going to get
coronavirus at which point you would
have three to four million deaths it
says if that's actually what they're
conceding and as people are pointing out
I'm being conservative but some people
are saying h1n1 was less Dane deadly
than the flu it was just very contagious
there was a very specific reason why
they stopped testing for h1n1 once it
was determined that there was no real
use to testing to distinguish it from
the flu the treatment was the same it's
just it's it's a you know it's a spare
tires to chicken thighs comparison like
it's just a ridiculous comparison in
total okay what else did I have there
was something else though that I wanted
to mention
yeah not nothing particularly urgent
about that I think I think that you
would all very much agree okay over on
twitch I am going to take people's
advice and we are going to raid Hasan
okay we I'm going to be wrapping here
but we are going to raid Hasan so please
join my raid we have not done any
raiding over on on Twitch for a while
my next chess coaching session I believe
is Monday I believe that that's going to
be Monday all right so let's go ahead
and do it thanks to everybody who tuned
in today we'll be back with more I am
sure very soon and on your way out if
you're leaving over on youtube please
hit that subscribe button and subscribe
to my channel if you're leaving on
twitch hit that follow button it's very
much appreciated
you